While it won’t make you into Iron Man,
this exosuit can help you walk like one.
Researchers at the Wyss institute in Massachusetts
have constructed a robotic exoskeleton
to help stroke victims regain use of their legs.
After a stroke, 9 out of 10 patients are partially
paralyzed, and left with an abnormal gait.
The soft robotic device provides assistance
to the joints in the lower leg.
The results were immediately visible.
With its mechanical help, the stroke victims
were able to maintain their balance,
and walk similar to the way they had prior to their
paralysis.
The patients could walk straight for several
minutes on a treadmill,
some without the aid of a handrail.
While previous assistive devices have been
made,
these were bulky and had to be tethered to a power source.
This new exosuit is light enough that it could
be used to help in overground therapy as well,
not just on a treadmill.
The researchers say that while it still needs
long term testing, the assistive device could
bring down the time needed for rehabilitation
after strokes.